flip 2017 flip challenge there's a real
arm here I can smell the advertise Gotti
the guy because of the flu for yeah you
the Moose but you can't just apply some
reasonable and a little brother which
week filming days because really
shouting guys we wanted to change a
million years to ascertain whether it
was on top of it
[Music]
[Applause]
what a way to sing as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go d-roc yeah you rocked on me I'm
kind of Airy let's go come on Tahrir
we also driftwood to you let me look
good just like thank you for having me
thank you thank you that's what got me
thank you thank you all this bike
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is an unpopular topic I think
selling out loud that you think you
actually believe but a lot of other
people don't agree hussein traffic if
you feel that that's isn't yeah that's
yeah you love being a contrarian yeah
this is a great game for contrarian
concern by the way I actually know that
about you and actually I know that about
you because the number one things that I
look for with employees is the one to
push against me because we think every
flick India for example right like you
know like push for the sake of pushing
and and like actually don't believe it
so I do believe what you just said I
think the current state of parenting is
fundamentally broken and will be looked
on as a bad place because I don't
believe in two cooks in the kitchen and
the blending
herding parenting not dividing convert
of the 1560s
actually is more ROI positive kind of
like higher thought of to cooks in the
kitchen that if there's a struggle
people agreeing on these things that
there is a little thing like I think we
often and I think if there's it's create
the Monday night experiment I think so
guys you have to put teeth around it
otherwise it's not going to work more
really it's gotta be things like
parenting there's got to be the taboo
[ __ ] I take you that there should be
plants offered with snow
let's say I say that's just a good idea
they're like oh airline you believe that
course under the rim like now like I
don't like flying
yeah I've always known you a bad person
I did the trick I drove right through
the sky I see what the bag was the
technology around the headphone I think
that nature it's become a dot back how
is your neck go away on the office right
now I didn't sport their bus device
[Music]
[Music]